francis you talked about uh setting up
that detector near the reactor so
uh but was that it did they suspect they
came from somewhere else as well from
you know they rhines
rhinos was one of the main architects of
the atomic bomb
and after the war
he had said that his his primary goal
to discover the neutrino to prove that
this particle really existed
and
so his first idea was very interesting
he was actually going you know in the
40s and 50s they were exploding bombs
left and right and bombs produced
neutrinos and so he was going to he was
looking for
a
healthy source of neutrinos and the
atomic bomb was it so he had the idea to
build a detector but of course the
detector you had to put it close to the
bomb so it would explode
the way you solve that is you you build
a
deep hole
and so as the bomb explodes your
detector starts falling in the hole
and so the time it falls you have the
time to do your experiment
and
and it's while he was thinking about is
there a graduate student holding that
i don't know where the graduate students
are
two of them
one for redundancy
so
but it's wiley was thinking about this
crazy idea which may have worked
actually is that he had the idea maybe
it's better to put it close to a nuclear
reactor